[Music]
june
28 1971 elon musk is born
musk was born on june 28 1971 in
pretoria south africa
the son of may musk a model and
dietitian from canada
and aeromusk a south african
electromechanical engineer
pilot and sailor he has a younger
brother kimball
and a younger sister tosca after his
parents divorced in 1980
musk lived mostly with his father in the
suburbs of pretoria
which musk chose two years after his
parents split up
but now musk says it was a mistake as an
adult musk has severed relations with
his father
whom he has referred to as a terrible
human being
1981 musk's childhood during his
childhood musk was an avid reader
at the age of 10 he developed an
interest in computing with the commodore
vic-20
he taught himself computer programming
at the age of 10 and by the age of 12
sold the code of a basic based video
game he created called
blast star to a magazine called pc and
office technology
for approximately 500 a web version of
the game is still
available online his childhood reading
included
isaac asimov's foundation series from
which he drew the lesson that
you should try to take the set of
actions that are likely to prolong
civilization minimize the probability of
a dark age and reduce the length of any
dark age
if there is one 1988
late teens and moving to canada at the
age of 17
in 1989 he moved to canada to attend
queens university
avoiding mandatory service in the south
african military
he left in 1992 to study business and
physics at the university of
pennsylvania
and graduated with an undergraduate
degree in economics and stayed for a
second bachelor's degree in physics
although his father insisted that he go
to college in pretoria
musk became determined to move to the
united states he said
i remember thinking and seeing that
america is where great things are
possible
more than any other country in the world
knowing it would be easier to get to the
united states from canada
he moved to canada against his father's
wishes in june 1989
just before his 18th birthday after
obtaining a canadian passport through
his canadian-born mother
he met his first wife canadian author
justine wilson
while both were students at ontario's
queen's university
they married in 2000 and separated in
2008.
their first son nevada alexander musk
died of sudden infant death syndrome
at the age of 10 weeks they later had
five sons through in vitro fertilization
twins in 2004 followed by triplets in
2008.
they share custody of all five sons
1995 starting zip2 in 1995 musk and his
brother kimball started zip2 a web
software company with money raised from
a small group of angel investors
the company developed and marketed an
internet city guide for the newspaper
publishing industry
musk obtained contracts with the new
york times and chicago tribune
and persuaded the board of directors to
abandon plans for a merger with city
search
while at zip2 musk wanted to become ceo
however
none of the other board members would
allow it compact acquired zip to for 307
million dollars in cash
and 34 million dollars in stock options
in february 1999.
musk received 22 million dollars for his
seven percent share from the sale
1999 creating paypal in march 1999
musk co-founded x.com an online
financial services and email
payment company with 10 million dollars
from the sale of zip2
one year later the company merged with
confinity which had a money transfer
service called paypal
the merged company focused on the paypal
service and was renamed to paypal in
2001.
paypal's early growth was driven mainly
by a viral marketing campaign where new
customers were recruited
when they received money through the
service in october 2002 paypal was
acquired by ebay for 1.5 billion dollars
in stock
of which musk received 165 million
before its sale musk who was the
company's largest shareholder owned 11.7
percent of paypal's shares
2001 the mars oasis project
in 2001 musk conceptualized mars oasis
a project to land a miniature
experimental greenhouse on mars
containing food crops
in an attempt to regain public interest
in space exploration
in october 2001 he traveled to moscow to
buy refurbished intercontinental
ballistic missiles
that could send the envisioned payloads
into space the group met with companies
however he was seen as a novice and was
consequently spat on by one of the
russian chief designers
so he returned to the united states
empty-handed in 2002 he met with them
again
and was offered one rocket for eight
million dollars however this was seen by
musk as too expensive musk consequently
stormed out of the meeting
on the flight back from moscow musk
realized that he could start a company
that could build the affordable rockets
he needed
ultimately musk ended up founding spacex
with the long-term goal of creating a
true space faring civilization
2002 starting spacex with 100 million
dollars of his early fortune musk
founded space exploration technologies
or spacex in may 2002
musk is the chief executive officer and
chief technology officer
of the hawthorne california based
company spacex develops and manufactures
space launch vehicles with a focus on
advancing the state of rocket technology
the company's first two launch vehicles
are the falcon 1
and falcon 9 rockets a nod to star wars
millennium falcon
and its first spacecraft is the dragon a
nod to puff the magic dragon
in seven years spacex designed the
family of falcon launch vehicles and the
dragon multipurpose spacecraft
in september 2008 spacex's falcon 1
rocket became the first
privately funded liquid-fueled vehicle
to put a satellite into earth orbit
on may 25th 2012 the spacex vehicle made
history as the first commercial company
to launch and birth a vehicle to the
international space station
2003 his involvement in tesla motors
tesla inc originally tesla motors was
incorporated in july 2003 by two
entrepreneurs
who financed the company until the
series a round of funding
both men played active roles in the
company's early development prior to
elon musk's involvement
musk led the series a round of
investment in february 2004
joining tesla's board of directors as
its chairman musk took an active role
within the company and oversaw roadster
product design at a detailed level
but was not deeply involved in
day-to-day business operations
2006 solar city startup musk provided
the initial concept and financial
capital for solarcity
which was then co-founded in 2006 by his
cousins lyndon and peter
by 2013 solarcity was the second largest
provider of solar powered systems in the
united states
solar city was acquired by tesla in 2016
and is currently a wholly owned
subsidiary of tesla
2007 becoming the ceo of tesla following
the financial crisis of 2008
and after a series of escalating
conflicts in 2007
the original founder of tesla was ousted
from the firm
musk assumed leadership of the company
as ceo and product architect
tesla motors first built an electric
sports car the tesla roadster in 2008
with sales of about 2 500 vehicles to 31
countries
2008 relationship with tallulah riley in
2008 musk began dating english actress
tallulah riley and in 2010 the couple
married
in january 2012 musk announced that he
had ended his four-year relationship
with riley
in july 2013 musk and riley remarried
in december 2014 musk filed for a second
divorce from riley the divorce was
finalized in late 2016.
2013 unveiling the hyperloop concept
on august 12 2013 musk unveiled the
concept for a high-speed transportation
system
incorporating reduced pressure tubes in
which pressurized capsules
ride on an air cushion driven by linear
induction motors and an air compressor
in june 2015 musk announced a design
competition for students and others to
build hyperloop pods
to operate on a spacex sponsored mile
long track
in the 2015-2017 hyperloop pod
competition
the track was used in july 2017 and musk
also started building a tunnel
2014 tesla technology patents
in 2014 musk announced that tesla would
allow its technology patents to be used
by anyone in good faith
in a bid to entice automobile
manufacturers to speed up development of
electric cars
2014 construction of the gigafactory 2.
on june 12 2014 musk committed to
building a solar city advanced
production facility in buffalo new york
that would triple the size of the
largest solar plant in the united states
musk stated the plant will be one of the
single largest solar panel production
plants in the world
and it will be followed by one or more
even bigger facilities in subsequent
years
construction on the factory started in
2014 and was completed in 2017.
2014 artificial intelligent warnings and
open ai
musk's dark warnings over artificial
intelligence have brought him some
controversy
he and facebook founder mark zuckerberg
have clashed with the latter calling his
warnings irresponsible musk responded to
zuckerberg censure by saying that he had
discussed ai with zuckerberg
and found him to have only a limited
understanding of the subject
in january 2015 he donated 10 million
to the future of life institute and
organization focus on challenges posed
by advanced technologies
in december 2015 he announced the
creation of open ai
a not-for-profit artificial intelligence
research company
openai aims to develop artificial
general intelligence in a way that is
safe and beneficial to humanity
2015 spacex rocket reusability
must believe that the key to making
space travel affordable is to make
rockets reusable
though most experts in the space
industry did not believe that reusable
rockets were possible or feasible
on december 22nd 2015 spacex
successfully landed the first stage of
its falcon rocket back on the launch pad
this was the first time in history that
such a feat had been achieved by an
orbital rocket
and is a significant step towards rocket
reusability lowering the cost of access
to space
the first stage recovery was replicated
several times in 2016 by landing on an
autonomous spaceport drone ship
in ocean based recovery platform aimed
by the end of 2017 spacex had landed and
recovered
the first stage on 16 missions in a row
where a landing and recovery were
attempted
2016 neurolink startup in 2016 he
co-founded neurolink a neurotechnology
startup company to integrate the human
brain with artificial intelligence
the company is centered on creating
devices that can be implanted in the
human brain
with the eventual purpose of helping
human beings merge with software
and keep pace with advancements in
artificial intelligence
these enhancements could improve memory
or allow more direct interfacing with
computing devices
december 2016 the boring company
on december 17 2016 while stuck in
traffic
musk tweeted am going to build a tunnel
boring machine
and just start digging the company was
named the boring company
in february 2017 the company began
digging a 30 foot wide 50 foot long
and 15 foot deep test trench on the
premises of spacex's offices in los
angeles
since the construction requires no
permit by late 2018 the boring company
had
active construction approved plans in
place or an operational tunnel in
several areas of the united states
baltimore chicago and los angeles the
born company provided an update on the
state of their technology and product
line when they opened to the public
their first mile-long test tunnel in
hawthorne california
on december 18 2018 stating that it had
been a proof of concept for the
technology
february 2018 falcon heavy launch
on february 6 2018 spacex successfully
launched the falcon heavy
the fourth highest capacity rocker ever
built after saturn v
energia and n1 and the most powerful
rocket in operation as of 2018.
the inaugural mission carried a tesla
roadster belonging to musk as a dummy
payload
september 2018 sec lawsuit
in september 2018 musk was charged by
the u.s securities and exchange
commission for a tweet claiming that
funding had been secured for taking
tesla
private the lawsuit characterized the
tweets as false
misleading and damaging to investors and
sought to bar bus from serving as ceo
on publicly traded companies two days
later musk reached a settlement with the
sec
as a result musk and tesla were fined 20
million dollars each
and musk was forced to step down as
tesla chairman within 45 days
while remaining tesla's ceo he also
proclaimed in several interviews since
that he does not regret sending the
tweet
that triggered the sec investigation he
said the tweet that would cost him and
the company 20 million dollars in fines
was
worth it september 2018 the joe rogan
interview controversy
in mid-september 2018 he appeared on the
joe rogan experience podcast
and discussed various topics within five
days the appearance had registered 10
million youtube views
one of the highest profile and
controversial aspects of the program was
musk's puffing from a cannabis-laced
cigarette
offered by rogan tesla stock dropped
after the incident
january 2019 his visit to china in
january 2019 he traveled to china for
the groundbreaking
of tesla's shanghai gigafactory which is
the company's first
large-scale plant outside of the us part
of his visit to china
musk also met the chinese premier during
the exchange musk confessed his love for
china and wished he could visit
china more often to which a chinese
premier was quoted the same
we can issue you a chinese green card if
that helps
if you want to see the top 50 rules
video we did on elon musk check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i i should if
people should think well
i feel fear about this and therefore i
shouldn't do it
um it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong if
you didn't feel fair